what are your thoughts on this statement
if you've seen a thousand films you've
lived a thousand lives
i
love filmmaking and a lot of the reason
why i love filmmaking is because i feel
like it transports you into
these different ways of navigating life
and being in different circumstances and
i really feel like film is this sense in
which if you've seen a thousand films
you've lived a thousand lives
and
does it have to be something that has a
quote unquote message or can it just be
a fun comedy a lot of the films that i
do
seek out to entertain and also provide a
message um but there is certainly a side
of of entertainment in itself that
is uh that uplifts people
um you know frank capra very early on um
made can't take it with you and um you
know just a number of films he was
nominated for for best oscar like time
and time again
and
they were all message based
um like mr smith goes to washington
and then preston sturges came out after
that and was like this is too much you
know there's something inherently good
about just entertainment that it really
lifts people up um and so
there's a huge spectrum and i think all
of it's valuable for me the really
important thing is is that entertainment
and storytelling has a huge
transformative power
and so i really seek to to educate and
also better understand for myself
about what that power is and and how it
can produce change
and speaking of frank capra um what
makes a good life
uh what makes a good life it's such a
it's such a good question i mean i think
for everybody it's
something they they ask individually or
should ask individually
i study philosophy and the core question
with that is
uh what is a good life um and sort of
philosophically
speaking and and in philosophy you
explore it through
uh
through telling stories which is also
why i i love philosophy so much um and
if the life lives
if the life ends in bliss then it's a
life worth living if it ends in despair
then it's it's not
um but largely i found that
uh if there's a one sort of category if
it's say okay to be a hedonist or to be
a stoic or to be this or that
that you really can't ever make a mold
fit your unique situation it's better to
kind of consider all these possibilities
and
but ultimately to ask yourself what it
is that you want and what you want your
your your
uh legacy to be
did anyone ever try to talk you out and
say you know robert just go have fun
just you know get out of your head like
you're young you know what you seem like
you you're sort of an old soul and and
you to be interested in in such heady
things and such deep things
uh fascinates me um it's a good question
multiple times my dad has been like you
need to be having fun you know when i
was like oh i'm gonna you know go to
berkeley and study philosophy people
were like i don't know if that's great
you know you're already you already
think a lot about things and but for me
that is fun right that is the sort of
like where meaning comes from and um
i've always found that through my work
it's a way of expressing and connecting
with the world and so the more that i
work the more that i engage uh you know
the community around me and people
around me um so it's always been very
very linked whether people have been
able to see it or not from the outside
bro so you gain energy from these deep
thoughts then it's not it's not
depressing oh cert certainly certainly
yeah it um it uh it absolutely fires me
up and and um
yeah there's also too it is
the great thing about art is it allows
you to
um
the great thing about art is it allows
you to express yourself and work through
your own things
um and so that has been uh
you know fantastic to explore as well
while also connecting with others and
there's a sort of
uh
thing i always tell myself of like
turning pain into productivity um sort
of you know taking things and
experiences and and um
even if it's just sort of stuck in
day-to-day doldrums and kind of using
that to um to to create
what makes a meaningful story i think
what makes a meaningful story is one
that
speaks to what it is to be a human that
is to be alive
and that really i think it comes down to
intent
in any films that i direct and ones that
i produce a central question is always
like what is it that i want to say
and i feel like
you can have entertainment but
even the entertaining films that don't
ask themselves what is it i want to say
with this film
uh sort of have a bit of a quick shelf
life
and so for me it comes down to the
intent um and and
the the narrative drive and uh the sort
of meaningful message that you put into
a particular work
how is a horror movie meaningful
horror is such a phenomenal genre
because it elicits such a strong
reaction and it pulls you so much out of
your head to literally be there on
screen and to connect with other people
in an audience
and
there is this
amazing way
science fiction is often talked about
this is you can create these metaphors
and you know this whole series was
actually about one thing when we thought
it was just entertainment on its core
and horror film i feel is the exact same
way and it struck me when i was first
watching the blob
and um
uh you know the blob is coming and
everybody's
yelling you know the blob is coming blob
is coming and people are partying and
kind of ignoring it and
um
and you realize that oh this is about
the red scare this is about what happens
if communism comes and takes over are
people just going to ignore it and this
blob is going to go and absorb
everything in its path
and
and that and other films other horror
films like that really opened my eyes to
wow this this
this art form and this
genre can can actually engage on on a
much deeper level
even if it's as a joke you know even if
it's um
if it's just kind of tongue-in-cheek but
that there's a lot more here in this
genre to to explore
how has philosophy impacted your film
career
uh philosophy has impacted my film
career in that
it's gotten me to fall in love again
with filmmaking
i think for
anybody
alive they look around and they see all
these problems in the world
and it's hard to
realize you're escaping it and it's hard
to
fall into your series fall into your
shows and and still
see all these things out there
and
realizing that my
love my love of filmmaking can
engage on these issues elevate these
topics or
um even just give a little bit of you
know life to other people and in what
they watch or get them to consider
things in different ways
um
really brought me back to filmmaking
that it wasn't just popcorn that it was
a it really had a
a very strong value and
you know they've often said
uh without science you know there would
be no life
um and and i think it's true of of art
you know without art there wouldn't be
you know life wouldn't be as as glorious
as it is
was there a school of thought or a
certain type of uh you know like
philosophical principle that you take
with you when you go on set um
uh i would say the the largest
uh philosophical influences on me are
mainly heideggerian which basically says
that
we are not separate from the world you
cannot define yourself as
i am here and the world is there that we
are all and and it's such a it's so
prevalent that he that heidegger even
tries to reinterpret our whole
understanding of being as amidst the
world so to say i'm in the world it like
that doesn't even make sense we are all
amidst the world and filmmaking is such
a to quina hannah orent term is such
action in concert
so many people coming together that for
me it's also a recognition of that
extreme vulnerability if somebody
doesn't want to come to set if
somebody's forgotten something if
a location isn't available all these
things or this action in concert
and put us in this extremely vulnerable
place to produce something that
um
[Music]
on paper at some point could could feel
impossible
and that we're all able to do it
together by leaning in by depending on
one another and then to at the end have
this thing that we get to go and and uh
eat popcorn and and and celebrate
together at a premiere
and sorry what was the principle called
again um so it's basically his entire
philosophy
um uh
it's his basically his theory of of
being um and so
it's it's
yeah he doesn't really have like a
specific um kind of school of thought
that that speaks to it but um
but largely people
who think like that or
um uh call themselves like heideggerians
or it's also taken up by um uh
uh another philosopher marilyn ponte
and then the person that i studied
closest with who who did this his name
was bert dreyfus
so if and forgive me i'm i'm rusty on my
philosophy but uh like ayn rand she was
more about like rugged individualism
yeah and so it sounds like this is the
opposite
so it's not so much about a lack of
individualism it's more about how you
look at yourself in relation to the
world
and so
it's where stoics say you are to be
completely detached and to shut down
or even buddhists right that say
um i'm equanimous
things change but i am going to you know
maintain my my
uh sense of peace and well-being
this
is
throw yourself into things throw
yourself into commitments
um that basically the best life is to be
completely
um committed to
a work or two people
um and that that is what uh as kirk
regard puts it as it sort of entwines
itself around every ligament of your
consciousness
and gives you a world and gives you
meaning